I don't give up easily I have walked two
marathons
so let's
go the men's room was
[Music]
disgusting
why you just Dive Right In you know
around age 12 I just started going for
it
no God oh help help what what happened I
fell off the
toilet I'm caught between the toilet and
the
wall what do you need not you someone
else get Pam I think Pam's gonna want to
come into the men's room get Ryan oh he
needs to lift me and he needs to clean
me up a little bit bring a wet towel
Ryan is uh dead no he's not I just saw
him no can't can you just get up
yourself I you only grilled your foot
yeah forget it I'll just get up myself
no
how oh oh God the point is I am the only
one here who has a legitimate disability
although I'm sure Stanley has had his
fair share of
obstacles I'm not disabled and neither
are you okay what does this look like to
you
Stanley mail bounes Etc shut yeah
okay well well you know what
disabilities are not things to be
laughed at or laughed about you people
are jerks imagine if you had left Stevie
Wonder on the floor of that bathroom
instead of me oh we wouldn't we love
Stevie
Wonder I've burned my foot I'm sorry
Michael David's in a meeting ah well
maybe you should spy on
him
oh my God wouldn't that be
hilarious um I'm I'll just have him call
you back okay good I'll catch you on the
flippity flip
bye he's busy call me back when he's
free Michael are you okay did you throw
up in there no I'm just pooping you know
how I be but it smells like throw up in
here crazy world a lot of smells did you
know you know that in Morocco it is
common to exchange a small gift when
meeting somebody for the first time in
Japan you must always commit suicide to
avoid
embarrassment in Italy you must always
wash your hands after going to the
bathroom this is considered to be polite
stop it bickering stop it really
yeah not much what's up with you n it's
okay I'm in the
bathroom hey you've been watching
damages this year it's so good now you
got to tune in it's as good as anything
on
HBO hey does blue go with tan who would
have thought that the thing that would
save this company would be work and
pancakes in the end this day definitely
had its ups and downs I realized that we
don't have the biggest office which is a
surprise because 165 ft sounds like a
lot
but we have people with the biggest
hearts and I think for a small company
that is
real found went to the
bath that is really what's
important you might be surprised to
learn that I have only been to one other
wedding it's actually a very cute story
my mom was marryed and Jeff and they
asked me to be ring bearer and I was
understandably emotional and somehow my
pants became
wet I hate you long story short Jeff's
dog ended up as ring bearer and the
irony is that after the ceremony that
dog
peed on everything and nobody said boo
sex different after the baby gym all
right we turn on some I need to pee no
you don't yeah I do my word against
yours all right well we'll be there in
10 minutes what part of I need to pee do
you not
understand I'm upset my bladder is full
there is no telling what I might do
right now all over the inside of your
precious little car all right well if I
see a gas station I'll pull over well I
hope I make
it just just stay there I I'll I'll be
there in one second
Michael
Michael excuse me sir there's a there's
a guy in the bathroom he's coming out
but I have to go because it's an
emergency will you just tell him to call
the office just call call the office
thank you
please
hello
I think it's horrible what Michael is
doing really I mean this is unacceptable
hello
gang hey did you ever notice that our
bathroom is right next to our kitchen
how's that up to
code I don't
know this is not fair what he's doing to
Dwight of course you think that heed to
bone the guy I think men bone women I
hate that I'm correcting that all I'm
saying is is that Dwight can't take the
blame for this it has to land on Michael
it's time for a reckoning it's true yeah
no no no no no no
no
Michael
Michael I do not want to talk about it
unbelievable that okay what happened
Michael oh wouldn't you like to know
what happened in the bathroom by myself
pervy suffice to say I finished my
business I was just checking to make
sure everything was fine and my cell
phone fell out and on not in but like on
the rim and then it fell in it's no just
let me tell the story okay Jim I knocked
it with my knee and then it fell in and
then I leaned over and looked and my Glu
tooth fell out of my ear and that fell
in and then I got FL must and everything
started falling in my wallet fell in my
tip calculator my candy corn my white
strips all fell in to the toilet and
your keys fell in I threw the keys in
out of anger right this cannot happen
again that's what you said last time I
know I did Phyllis this is not funny
this is not
funny well technically it is toilet
humor which you claim to enjoy it is not
toilet humor it is toilet
tragedy
hey hey you know
what this is the best thing that ever
happened to
me I don't doubt
it ladies and gentlemen a while ago you
witnessed a tragedy that befell me in
the bathroom but As the adage goes
out of great
tragedy is the mother of invention so
without further Ado I would like to
present to you something that I believe
will change the way that we all do
business so to speak
behold the mesh toilet guard handy
portable
self-cleaning this little baby goes
where you
go who wants to give it a test spin
Phyllis Stanley
cev want
to who wants to take it on its maiden
voyage
anyone come
on Mr Scott do you realize you just
contradicted yourself I did yes you did
can I go to the bathroom no I really
have to I've been drinking lots of water
you went 5 minutes ago that wasn't to go
to the bathroom that was to get out of a
question you still have to answer it
first can I go to the bathroom
no everybody takes a Subway in New York
it's fast it's efficient get you there
on time it's a way to okay there's a guy
pooping in a cardboard box down
there